a killer goes on a shooting spree in a
New Zealand mosque why did he do it we
will analyse his manifesto as well as
underreported religious violence around
the globe then Nancy Pelosi wants kids
to vote bado raises a pile of cash and I
defend Chelsea Clinton oh heavens she's
my cousin actually technically I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
a lot to talk about today obviously the
big story is this slaughter that
happened in New Zealand basically the
entire media apparatus is getting this
wrong they are doing exactly what the
guy said they were going to do what he
predicted what he wanted them to do it's
just a mess it's a mess of a reaction
people are getting it wrong on both
sides so we're gonna go in depth on on
why he did this well what the shooting
means what the shooting means in context
of larger religious violence around the
world but first let's make a little
money honey with Dollar Shave Club you
know that I love Dollar Shave Club they
send me everything that I need to look
feel and smell my best you never have to
go to the store with Dollar Shave Club
this is the great thing because what I
would do is I'd use the same crusted old
disposable razor for eight months at a
time giving myself tetanus every day
because I didn't want to walk three feet
to the drugstore
now you can have Dollar Shave Club send
everything you need right to your door
they keep you fully stocked on what you
use so you don't run out Dollar Shave
Club has everything you need they have
this program where they automatically
keep you stocked on the products you use
and especially I want to focus on Dollar
Shave Club toothpaste because I'm one of
these guys you know I get to the end of
the toothpaste and I'm lazy and cheap
enough where I won't go I will not get
more toothpaste so I'm just scraping the
bottom pushing giving myself carpal
tunnel to get the last dregs of
toothpaste out for months at a time
don't be like that
don't do that Dollar Shave Club will
send toothpaste right to you there
they're a fad it's a fabulous product
right now they got a bunch of starter
sets you can try for just five bucks
like the oral care kit after that the
restock box ships regular size products
at regular price what are you waiting
for get your starter set for just five
bucks right now dollarshaveclub.com
slash cough fa ce o-- v fe fe that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa co v
fe fe what happened in New Zealand
here's what we know we know that a 28
year old personal trainer former
bodybuilder went into a mosque Live
Streaming with a bunch of guns and
killed 49 Muslims at a mosque at their
house of worship
he just before he went in he released a
manifesto online at 73 74 pages it
explains why he did it
but it's a difficult document unless you
are steeped in Internet language unless
you're steeped in various ideologies on
both the left and the right unless you
have some context with which to read
this manifesto you can get it very wrong
as a ton of people on social media and
in traditional media the mainstream
media did on Friday and Saturday they
just were not equipped to read this
document so they didn't know exactly
what it meant the question is should
people read the manifesto you know this
this document was hosted on a few
websites Scribd a few others and some
media were posting it and some media
outlets said we don't want to publish
the manifesto daily wire I think said
we're not going to publish the manifesto
we're not going to give this guy extra
publicity totally get that that makes a
lot of sense to me
however the document cloud services like
Scribd that people had uploaded it to
also took down the manifesto this I
think is a huge mistake because to say a
place like Daily wire or CNN or Fox or
whatever that they're not going to
publish it right there is no reason to
totally give this guy an open platform
but to say that the Internet is going to
censor this document you can't find it I
wasn't able to find it after I first
read it then it was gone I had to search
and have people send me copies of it
just to be able to read it this is a bad
idea because what it the message that it
sends is that this document is explosive
it's dangerous
people can't be trusted to read it why
maybe it contains all sorts of truths
that the conspiracy doesn't want you to
read and which is not what is going on
here what is actually happening is these
document cloud services are getting a
lot of public pressure they don't want
to give this guy publicity they don't
want to be seen as agreeing with this
guy's content they're being cowed by
censorious mobs
that that actually if anything or giving
the shooter more credit than he deserves
the reality is
the ideas that he's espousing her bad
ideas he's asking questions he's coming
up with bad answers to those questions
and then he's using those bad answers to
justify killing a ton of innocent people
those those are bad ideas the way to
stop those bad ideas is to refute them
not to ignore them not to dismiss them
not to say that they're so dangerous
we're not gonna put no take them on
head-on there's nothing mystical or or
secret or really wise in these documents
they're bad ideas and we should refute
them that I think isn't what you've got
to deal with ideology head-on if you
ignore it you give it a dangerous cachet
and people are gonna seek it out and
they're gonna read it out of context and
they might draw a pretty bad conclusions
what the guy did is not defensible it's
not defensible ideologically it's not
obviously not defensible religiously
it's it's not defensible politically so
the ideas that he espouses are only
powerful if they are not shown to be as
wrong as they are so let's get to it
then
the manifesto I'm not gonna go through
and read the whole manifesto or anything
like that if you can still find it
online
I guess you're welcome to I'm just gonna
go for the most important parts that I
think show the questions he's asking how
he goes so wrong and how he he perverts
these things to try to justify killing a
lot of innocent people
the manifesto is called the great
replacement the great replacement and
the introduction says it's the
birthrates it's the birth rates
it's the birth rates ethnic replacement
cultural replacement racial replacement
white genocide so write what you know
from the first page of this is that this
is boilerplate white supremacist
ideology this is not particularly
inventive this is not this this one guys
you know really profound insight into a
certain ideology this is boilerplate
white supremacism who is the guy's a
28-year old white guy he says he's not
terribly educated he didn't do well in
school he didn't go to college
and he travelled extensively throughout
the Middle East Muslim countries
European countries obviously then he's
in Australia he went over to New Zealand
the birth rates the birth rates the
birth rates this is pretty interesting
timing in so much as you've got
governments across the West trying to
address this problem we were just
talking on Thursday about how the new
proposals being pushed by Democrats and
Republicans by the whole government or
to deal with the problem of birth rates
right now the United States has a
less-than replacement birth rate now
what this guy says is it's white people
the white people have low birth rates
and this is the problem because the
white people are gonna disappear
actually the the issue of birth rates is
not just white people in the United
States you're seeing huge declines of
birth rates among all native-born
Americans most especially actually not
among whites but among Hispanics but
same same thing with black Americans all
sorts of Americans so it's it's another
one of these examples where a little
learnin is a dangerous thing you focus
on one partial truth when you ignore
other truths you can create this
ideology and go down a real wormhole
that ultimately he's going to use to
justify violence but the issue is not
racial here in America it's a cultural
it's it's social the birthrate issue is
is a broader issue across the entire
country across demographic groups not
just among white people so why did he
commit the slaughter is what he says he
says quote to most of all show the
invaders that our lands will never be
their lands he's referring to these
Muslims as invaders to add momentum to
the pendulum swings of history further
destabilizing and polarizing Western
society and finally to create conflict
between the two ideologies within the US
on the ownership of firearms in order to
further divide the social cultural
political and racial divide within the
US this conflict over the Second
Amendment and the attempted removal of
firearms rights will ultimately result
in a civil war that will eventually
balkanize the u.s. along political
cultural most importantly racial lines
so I said boilerplate white supremacist
ideology this is what they've been
talking about for seventy years it's
it's the same thing they're just pushing
for the up
coming race war what this guy wants is
not to achieve some limited terrorist
objective what he wants to do is
destabilize the United States so the
first thing he obviously gets wrong here
is he refers to these Muslims in New
Zealand as invaders they're not invaders
regardless of what you think about the
issue of immigration of immigration
across you know various continents
across oceans into the United States
wherever they're not invaders they're
being invited in by the countries the
the Muslims who immigrated to New
Zealand didn't illegally cross the
border to New Zealand the the border to
New Zealand is a giant ocean they were
invited in by the country so just that
language invader is disingenuous this
guy's real problem I guess would be with
politicians who advocate for lacs
immigration policies or open borders or
whatever but to call these people who
were innocent and were peaceful praying
in a mosque invaders is simply a lie
it's not true then to add momentum to
the pendulum swings of history further
destabilizing and polarizing Western
society what he wants is not to make
Western society better that's not the
goal he explicitly says that's not the
goal
it's to make Western society worse and
worse and worse until it's so bad that
there's an all-out war and he can create
a new society
this is his death no utopian plan I mean
it says toward a toward a new society
and the title of the manifesto so the
premise here is that the society is
already so awful that the best thing to
do is make life so much worse for
everybody that it'll all turn to rubble
and then the ethno white supremacist
utopian society can finally take off
that's his premise and this is important
to understand because his tactics will
make a lot more sense to observers to
commentators once you realize that his
purpose is to make everything worse so
here you see this and that's the next
lines he won
to further conflict between the two
ideologies within the US so he's doing
this in New Zealand he's an Australian
guy but his audience is the United
States he wants us politicians to fight
over this specifically over firearms so
specifically over the Second Amendment
he sees the Second Amendment as this
perfect wedge issue because it's in the
Constitution you can't get rid of this
right without basically launching
another American Revolution and what he
wants to do is use firearms to get the
left so riled up over firearms that they
try to undo and overturn the
Constitution which will get the right so
riled up that you will see a civil war
in the United States that's why he used
the guns he could have used other other
weapons as he talks about later on but
instead he uses the guns he then asks
himself what do you want his answer is
the famous fourteen words you know
partially what gave me some context for
reading this manifestos I did a video
for Prager University on the alt-right
back when that word meant something now
the left uses all right to describe
anybody to the right of Hillary Clinton
but Hillary Clinton did actually the
same thing but the term alt-right in a
really narrow sense is an alternative to
conservative thought so this encompasses
a wide variety of ideologies but all of
them basically boil down to white
identitarian ism or white supremacism or
white nationalism or whatever you want
to call it it this is difficult to
discuss because the left abuses these
terms so much that they water it down so
it means nothing but there actually is
an ideology here that we're talking
about it is a a fundamentally racial
ideology that is motivating this guy and
so he the fourteen words are we must
secure the existence of our people and a
future for white children that's what it
boils down to when he uses that phrase
he's not coming up with some new
ideology is saying I am part of this
very specific ideological realm that
that flourishes on the Internet
and and and that is where this is that
is how you can understand what I'm doing
so the first takeaway very
important to note this guy is not insane
in the way that other mass shooters are
insane when you look at shooters like
who is the one in in Newtown the guy
looked like a lunatic or the Aurora
Colorado they've got you saw his image
he looks like it truly bonkers out of
his mind can't string three words
together because he's got a severe
psychological problem this guy is
different than that he's got a severe
ideological problem he might have some
psychiatric issues as well very likely
he does but his problem primarily is not
insanity it's a wicked ideology that's a
very important difference because you
can't engage rationally you can't refute
you can't debunk an insane person he's
just an insane person you can and must
refute wicked ideologies that is
incumbent on us to do and it's why the
reaction has to be different if the guy
in Aurora Colorado wrote a manifesto you
know in crayon backwards and it didn't
make sense there's no reason to read it
there's no reason to talk about it if
you nothing would be gained from that
but if somebody under the spell of a
wicked ideology writes a manifesto you
do have to read it so that you can
understand and and see how things can go
wrong and try to prevent other people
from going wrong and have answers to bad
ideas he does have some similarities to
the other shooters in that it appears he
has daddy issues we've talked about this
with a lot of these mass shooters the
fathers weren't at home the fathers had
died the fathers were divorced this is
one common thread amongst so many of
these shooters the vast majority of
these mass shooters this guy's no
different his father apparently divorced
his mother when he was very young they I
guess he still saw his father maybe or
his father was still alive and all of
the neighbors said oh he was such a nice
boy oh he seemed perfectly fine his
co-workers always seemed perfectly
normal until coincidentally his father
died his father died in 2010 that seems
to be the moment when this guy cracked
when this guy went on traveling
excursions throughout the Middle East
when he started to hatch his plans when
he started to become seats steeped in
this white supremacist ideology and
ultimately then when he launched this
attack so there is that commonality that
is the one psychological factor that
people should talk about and it's gone
basically unreported so then he doesn't
interview with himself because he knows
that the the media are going to distort
this or misrepresent this he actually
talks about that in the manifesto but he
is making his his motivations clear
because he is an ideologue he's driven
by ideas insane as those ideas might are
perverted as those ideas might become so
he says quote was there a particular
event or reason you decided to commit a
violent attack
he said he traveled around his Muslim
areas he traveled around Europe he saw
that Europe had a lot of terrorist
attacks in Europe had a lot of Muslim
immigrants and so he decided that he was
going to take revenge by killing a lot
of innocent people and this is a
question that comes up is this guy
reacting to events and then you and then
having those events prompt his actions
or is this a guy who just wanted to go
kill a lot of people and used events and
used observations to justify them it
seems clear to me it's the latter he's
presenting it as though it's the former
he's saying I'm just reacting I just saw
all these Muslim immigrants so I'm
reacting for my country or something I
think it's very clear from the rest of
the manifesto that this guy wanted to go
out there and kill a lot of people and
he's backtracking and justifying it in
his head but we'll see why that is he
then asks did you carry out the attack
for fame you know a lot of these guys
want to be famous they want to go down
in history he insists quote no carrying
out an attack for fame would be
laughable after all who can remember the
name of the attackers on 9/11 how about
the attack in the Pentagon the attackers
in the plane that crashed in the field
I'll be forgotten quickly which I do not
mind do we believe him on the one hand
this guy obviously has a grandiose
vision of himself he's clearly a loner
he was isolated he got isolated on the
Internet
travelled alone so on the one hand he
seems to have this inflated ego and and
want this inflated ego so it seems to me
he might want Fame on the other hand
again a difference between lunatics true
mentally ill people and people who are
under the sway of a perverse ideology
this guy's a true believer this guy's
ideology while not coherent in a broad
sense has some trappings of internal
consistency I bet he believes it I don't
think he's using the ideology as some
facade I don't think he's he's fooling
us with the ideology I think he really
buys it and so in that sense maybe he
doesn't really care about Fame in that
sense maybe his motivations are
different than other killers motivations
so he says why did you choose to use
firearms he says I could have chosen any
weapons or means gas fire vehicular
attacks plane attacks any means were
available I had the will and I had the
resources
I chose firearms for the effect it would
have on social discourse the extra media
coverage they would provide and the
effect it would have on social discourse
the the the politics of the United
States the political situation of the
world the u.s. is torn into many
factions with enough pressure the
left-wing within the US will seek to
abolish the Second Amendment this will
start a civil war okay he has now stated
this twice in the manifesto he no we
know that this is a major motivation
what happens within hours of the attack
politicians in New Zealand focus on the
guns politicians in the United States
focus on the guns the media in the
United States focus on the guns people
on social media focus on the guns but
the guns are not the issue he's right I
mean he's right when he says he could
have used other weapons he course he
could have used other weapons and he
chose the guns specifically not to make
the world a better place not even to
make his bizarre vision of society
happen gradually get closer to that but
to actually
plunge society into some chaos and then
in the rubble he thinks in his fish
istic vision he's going to be able to
remake the world as he wants to
now it's an attack on a mosque so
forgetting the guns he's kind of Troy
he's setting up the gun this is the big
debate but the question is is this guy
primarily motivated by religion is that
because it's obviously an attack on a
house of worship
so is he a well he asks himself he says
do you personally hate Muslims he says a
Muslim man or woman living in their
homelands no a Muslim man or woman
choosing to invade our lands live on our
soil and replace our people yes I
dislike them this is a very important
line because what it shows us is that
this attack is not primarily about
religious bigotry this attack primarily
is motivated by racial bigotry so you're
hearing people say that this is a prime
example of Islamophobia
now obviously Islam plays some role in
this but it's pretty clear from his
ideology from this line from the whole
rest the whole context the whole title
of the manifesto though replacement that
this is actually not really about
religion he says he's fine with Muslims
having their own lands now what does it
mean to it for a Muslim to have his own
land before Islam existed those lands
belong to other people of other
religions why isn't it their lands
because this guy's ideology is is purely
racial he doesn't really care about the
ideas he doesn't really care some people
you know genuinely have great disputes
with Islam for them the the religious
battle is the is the first and most
important battle not for this guy it's
about brown people it's about people
with a different culture but it's about
race finally it's about race it's about
the race of people living in New Zealand
he asks where are you a Christian he
says that's complicated when I know I
will tell you which is to say no when
you ask someone are you a Christian and
they say well it's really complicated
well I dunno it just the answer is no if
you're a Christian you know and you say
yes and you profess your faith this guy
is not a Christian
so now we have both sides of it to say
this is not primarily a religious
terrorist attack this is a racial
terrorist attack something we already
knew now the right wing in the US and
discourse is calling this a leftist
attack because this guy has a lot of
leftist ideas the left is calling this a
right-wing attack because this guy has a
lot of very far-right ideas so which is
it
he said he asks where are you a
conservative no conservatism is
corporatism in disguise I want no part
of it again if you if you want a little
more insight on this go to my video that
I did for Prager you on the alternative
right the alt I think some people hear
that word is alt right like ultimate or
final or most right no no it's alt for
alternative it's an alternative to what
would be called the conservative
tradition from say Edmund Burke and
Russell Kirk and those kind of people
this is an alternative to that now does
that mean that it's not right-wing it's
not it's not that simple
does he have a lot of left-wing ideas
yes what is one of his essential
motivations environmentalism how is that
possible we'll get to it in a second a
lot more of this to get to and and
ultimately to try to answer the question
why did the shooter do it but first we
have to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube if you're on Facebook and
YouTube go over to Daily wire calm ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
reclaim and show you got the ben shapiro
show you get the Matt Walsh oh you get
to ask questions in the mailbag coming
up on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom you
get all this stuff you get the leftist
ears tumblr very important the only
fda-approved vessel for salty delicious
leftist ears go to daily wire.com we'll
be right back with a lot more
is this killer right-wing or left-wing
he says very explicitly I'm not a
conservative I want no part of
conservatism or the conservative
tradition so then he says were are you a
fascist yes for once the person that
will be called a fascist is an actual
fascist and he is a fascist
he's very specifically an eco fascist an
environmentalist fascist we'll get to
that in a second now I know a lot of
right-wingers want to say fascism is
purely a leftist ideology it's socialism
it's the National Socialist German
Workers Party
it's socialists in Italy it's socialism
so it's on the left there's some truth
to that fascism does have a lot of
elements that are very left-wing
specifically economically
however fascism does have a kind of
idolatry of the tradition it takes a lot
of elements that are right wing and
really perverts them but it does draw on
elements that are right-wing as well so
a little bit it's a little mixture here
so we're are you a socialist depending
on the definition sure worker ownership
of the means of production depends on
who the workers are and really what he
means there is my race if it's my race
of workers working for someone who's not
of our race then I want the workers to
take over like communists so yes he
that's a very left-wing point of view
he's a socialist economically possibly
did you always hold these views no when
I was young I was a communist then an
anarchist and finally a libertarian
before becoming an eco fascist what is
an eco fascist an eco fascist he's a
fascist
he's a collectivist nationalist
racialist authoritarian who says that
the environment is utterly important to
fascism the natural environment is part
of the people and this is where you get
to where he goes so wrong religiously
because it is almost a worship of the
creation not to create
but the creation he is saying because I
am so idolized the nation in the race
itself that even the trees next to where
the race was born even the landscape of
the nation that is so much more
important than other aspects of society
profits or immigration or
cosmopolitanism or culture what I was
saying of race the soil the trees the
dirt the hills
that's the Eco part of that now you
might say Khali was a communist that's
left-wing then an anarchist is that I
think that's left-wing some people say
that's right wing but I think it's
left-wing a libertarian well there are
two kinds of libertarians the Left
libertarians and the right libertarians
then an eco fascist okay the truth about
his political views is they don't fit
neatly on the right or the left anybody
who tells you he's a left winger is
oversimplifying anybody who tells you
he's a right winger is oversimplifying
this is something so out of the
mainstream that cynical politicians and
cynical media people are going to want
to use this and say see it's my
opponents it's not my views it is more
complicated than that it's that's just
an oversimplification
I mean just just that combination he
talks about the tradition or people are
we have to draw back on our you know
make our tradition great again and
saying there's no traditionalism without
the environmentalism this is a
connection that we don't talk about very
much
but because now the left basically owns
environmentalism the idea of the right
is that the right just likes profits at
all costs and economic progress and we
don't really care about the natural
environment that's a kind of new
development in the history of political
philosophy that that breakdown of the
left and right doesn't hold up for long
periods of history and so basically
whoever is trying to tell you to sell
you a simple view of this guy's politics
reject it it's it's not a simple view
it's it is its its own ideology it's its
own
ideology okay so he knows the media are
going to start pointing fingers he wants
them to start pointing fingers and so
beyond just the left and the right who
can we blame he asks himself were are
you a supporter of Donald Trump
immediately the left wanted to blame
Trump for this he says quote as a symbol
of renewed white identity and common
purpose sure as a policymaker and leader
dear God
no so what we have here is he says do
you support Donald Trump he says in
theory if Donald Trump were what I
wanted Donald Trump to be then yes I
would support Donald Trump but in
reality dear God
No so he says explicitly I I don't
support Donald Trump cynical people who
oppose Donald Trump are gonna try to
exploit this and say see he views Trump
as a symbol of white identity and white
common purpose but then he says one
sentence later in reality I don't
support Donald Trump it's an important
distinction
so he doesn't support Trump and actually
it's worth pointing out when he says
dear God no God is with a lowercase G
this will tell you another something
about his view his right-wing views or
as traditional views or his conservative
views he is not capitalizing God he's
not showing a whole lot of respect for
God or religion because his religion is
not Christianity his religion is not the
traditional religion of his so-called
people his religion is the race itself
that's how it gets so perverted he then
asks were you taught violence in
extremism by video games music
literature and cinema his response yes
spyro the dragon three taught me
ethno-nationalism fortnight trained me
to be a killer and to floss on the
corpses of my enemies no so this is
trolling he's making a joke Eve even
while he's making direct points he is
making jokes so obviously no spyro the
dragon didn't teach him about
ethno-nationalism right he learned that
by reading
blogs on the internet presumably what
that line also tells us is this is a guy
steeped in Internet steeped in Internet
culture first of all I don't know any of
these video games I don't and I'm on the
internet you're watching me on the
Internet or listening to me on the
Internet
right now this is a guy who is in inside
gamer culture he like the verb to floss
this is I guess some sort of dance move
I didn't know that until I googled it so
this is a guy who's he's traveled around
the world but he lived on the Internet I
mean that's where he was you get an
image of a guy who's isolated who's
talking to presumably the most sinister
people on earth who is blurring the line
between reality and humor and and and
earnestness this brings us to the to the
most controverted part of the manifesto
so in the manifesto he he asks himself
is there a particular person that
radicalized you the most and his answer
is yes the person that has influenced me
above all with Candice Owens each time
she spoke I was stunned by her insights
and her own views helped push me further
and further into this belief of violence
over meekness though I will have to
disavow some of her beliefs the extreme
actions she calls for or too much even
for my tastes now this especially read
in context with the video game answer is
obviously irony it's sarcasm he was not
radicalized by Candice Owens what he's
actually saying is he's laughing at the
question he's saying no there's not a
particular person who influenced and
radicalized him the most he does
actually refer to certain fascist
thinkers in other parts and certain
schools of fascist thought over time so
and that might be a more earnest to
answer the question but he's laughing at
the question he's then calling Candice
Owen stupid he's saying she doesn't have
insights and her views are not terribly
insightful and and and then he says I
mean this is the moat this is how you
know for sure that he's making a joke he
is he says her extremism is too much for
me
this is a guy who just killed nearly 50
people in a mosque
Candace Owens talks on the Internet
obviously she's not too extreme for him
and so he's making fun of her why does
he mention her it's also ironic that a
white supremacist would say that this
black girl is the is the great insight
insightful person he says that he
rejects conservatism she is now one of
the biggest spokesman for conservative
thought he says he hates Donald Trump in
reality she is one of the favored
spokesmen from Donald Trump Donald Trump
references her so obviously he's being
ironic here the media ran with us I mean
this they said Candace Owens was the
inspiration for this attack that is
simply not true that's just not true and
the other place you see this internet
humor he responds to a point he's where
the point was you're a bigot a racist a
xenophobe
and then he responds to that by saying
what the f did you effing say about me
you little bee I'll have you know I
graduated the top of my class in the
Navy SEALs I've been in numerous secret
raids he goes on and on he's making fun
of an Internet thread discussion he's
making fun of Internet anonymous Twitter
culture he's making fun of the place
that he lives which is the Internet so
why does he commit violence he commits
violence he talks about the failure of
assimilation this is another thing that
people are getting really really wrong
because the object of his ire in the
manifesto is not really the people that
he just slaughtered the object of his
ire is his own culture it's a sort of
self-hatred of his own culture he says
he's not blaming immigrants for not
assimilating into Europe or America or
Australia New Zealand he's blaming the
culture itself he says expecting
immigrants to assimilate to a dying
decadent culture is laughable now if his
ideas were actually coherent who were
really coherent then he would unleash
his terrorist attack on his own
people his own culture but because of
the idolatry of the race because he
doesn't ultimately need all these ideas
to make sense because he hates the
racial other then he just goes out and
attacks the brown people but if his
ideas had more coherence then you can
see where that insight would be in that
line and so what does the future look
like the future basically looks pagan
people are blaming white people for this
attack or Christians for this attack or
what it no they're missing the point the
future is this guy sees it is pagan
he says green nationalism is the only
true nationalism we were born from our
lands and our culture was molded by
these same lands it's the lands it's the
it's the folk in the lands it's this
worship of the creation he says there is
no green future with never-ending
population growth so he comes out
against population growth too we talked
to a week or two ago about how this is
one place you can always see where ideas
go perverse when they start trying to
limit the number of humans who are born
this is where you see the mark of the
devil it happens in abortion it happens
with people trying to kill off old
people in euthanasia when you're just
trying to kill off humans to lower the
populations it's the mark of the devil
the devil does not want more people and
neither does this guy
says we can't have all of this
population growth now why in part it's
because of the idolatry of nature says
it'll hurt the environment if we have
too many people born the natural
environment does not exist so that human
beings can serve it that is a an
inversion of the natural order the
natural environment exist so that we can
steward it and enjoy it but that the
court cannot wag the dog I'm confusing
to metaphors but the the tail cannot wag
the dog here that is an inversion
he says the present is a gift from those
in our past so here you see there's the
nature worship and the ancestor
worship this is a gift from those in our
past the worship of the father's here
you see maybe questions of these daddy
issues now I I love our ancestors
I love the the Giants on which we stand
I think it's wonderful I think it's
wrong to spit on them and tear down
their statues that's wrong neither
should we worship them I mean this is a
big difference what he is talking about
which is an essentially pagan idea is
quite different from the Christian idea
in James it is written every good gift
and every perfect gift is from above
coming down from the Father of lights
with whom there is no variation or
shadow due to change now what this guy
says is every good gift comes from the
past comes from below comes from the
earth comes from our human fathers but
that is utterly at odds with the
Christian idea so he says venerate the
ancestors but work for the children he's
not talking about worshiping God that's
where the where the real perversion sets
in and he says we need a soldiers fight
expect a soldier's fight and have a
soldier's death here he's just a coward
here is just a pitiful coward he didn't
have a soldiers fight he went in and he
slaughtered innocent people who were
unarmed who were praying it just it's
like sucker punching a guy it's just I
mean obviously it's much worse than that
but that's what the analogy is it's not
a fair fight it's not a soldiers fight
there's nothing glorious about what he
did he's just a mass murderer he didn't
he didn't have the thing that he's
calling for he didn't have the glory
that he's calling for he's basically
they would call it LARPing he's just
playing around in his head he's got a
little story of himself in his head and
he's playing it out but there's nothing
but cold-blooded killing and then he
says at the end I will see you in
Valhalla
not I will see you in heaven I will see
you in Valhalla
what is Valhalla in Norse mythology
Valhalla is the whole of the slain it's
over overruled it's ruled by the Norse
god Odin this is ultimately paganism and
all this white supremacist stuff when
you go back far enough it just ends up
becoming a sort of neo-pagan
oh gee it's not Christian it's a it's a
worship of the creation of the
attributes of creation race ethnicity
land hills mountains fathers
grandfathers tradition now these things
in their proper place look tradition is
very important to to all political views
tradition either your rebelling against
the tradition or your trying to channel
the tradition as the newest thing but a
worship of the tradition is when things
go totally wrong this this becomes a
pagan ideology and so who's to blame for
the shooting well the media offer us a
lot of options guns Islamophobia
immigration the news media gun laws
who's to blame for the shooting this guy
this guy is to blame not Donald Trump
not Candace Owens not Chelsea Clinton
someone blame Chelsea Clinton for the
shooting some Bernie Sanders supporter
not any of that this guy is to blame
this guy wanted to kill a lot of people
that's ultimately what it comes down to
if he were motivated purely by ideology
this is how you know it goes so if let's
say that his ideology for whatever
internal consistency it has if he were
motivated purely by ideologies and the
replacement is the issue and the
demographics are the issue and we're not
having kids and we don't have a
traditional culture if he were motivated
purely by ideology he would have gotten
married and had kids instead of becoming
a 28 year old loner loser who shot up a
mosque he would have done but he wasn't
motivated purely by ideology he's
clearly an angry young man who wanted to
kill some people who had an ideologies
that helped him along to do it then
maybe he believed in very seriously but
there was that aspect as well if he were
motivated by the preservation of his own
culture he would have participated in
his culture it would have participated
in the religion that made his culture he
didn't do that
his ideologies did not ultimately cohere
it's ultimately it so it has a rough
sketch of coherence but it's not
ultimately a coherent ideology what's
the right reaction to this shooting
don't exploit it for your own purposes
try to understand it you should try to
understand it because there was some
ideological motivation figure out why it
was wrong be able to explain why it was
wrong and and also the other the other
part is not just to look at this totally
in isolation this is not the only
terrible event that's happened in the
world this is not the only racial or
religious motivated killing that's
happened in the world and that this is
where the media actually come into play
this is where some hypocrisy comes into
play but a month and a half ago January
27th Islamic militants bombed a
Cathedral in the Philippines killing 20
and leaving dozens wounded Isis took
responsibility jihadists in Nigeria have
killed 120 Quist Christians in the last
three weeks in multiple attacks 52
Christians killed last Monday another 17
the day before that week before that
killed 30 right before that killed
another 38 just today a Turkish
terrorists murdered three and wounded
nine people on a tram in the Dutch city
of Utrecht so you're going to see people
cynically
say it's that this this is the big
problem the only problem that matters is
white supremacist ideology of course
that isn't true of course that's not the
soul and it's a numbers game it's not
even close to the the biggest religious
persecution and religious killing in the
world
nowhere near I mean not orders a
magnitude away so honest people genuine
people can look at that attack go
through it with a fine-tooth comb find
everything that was wrong what motivated
it look at it head-on
say hmm some right-wing ideas could help
this along some left-wing ideas did to
look dead on at it and yet probably
those other killings you might not have
heard about them in the last three weeks
why because of that double standard
because of that hypocrisy and that is
the soft bigotry of low
stations that is it's a line from
Michael Gerson a speechwriter for Bush
the reason I think that the media only
focus on the rare attack from a white
supremacist or somebody motivated like
that they focus on that with so much
more attention than on Islamic terrorist
attacks which happen more frequently and
they do that because of the soft bigotry
of low expectations because basically
they think oh you know Muslims just do
this they just have the they attack
people like this oh that's just what
that we can't expect more of them but
when white people do it that's the big
issue that because we should expect so
much more of them that is an essentially
racist or Islamophobic or whatever word
you want to use
that's a bigoted position and that is
the position that dominates our public
discourse so I want it you know we have
so much more to get to we can't get to
it today
because we had to focus on this the
whole time but I wanted to be really
really thorough because I think at least
somewhere on the internet somewhere in
discourse over this people should really
analyze this for for everything it's got
the the perversity of the ideology the
wickedness of the attack and the
shallowness of the reaction because if
you only go for those cynical shallow
exploitative reactions then you're doing
what the guy wants you to do and
predicted that you would do all right
that's our show we have got a lot more
than we'll get to tomorrow but we'll
have to get to it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19